[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen schönen
freitagabend und katja als hätten wir
ein abo er wieder deutsches olympia-gold
im angebot
dann hab ich zum glück land hier ist
unser überblick
wie umgehen mit russischer provokation
die westlichen bündnispartner darunter
deutschland und die usa beraten über
eine gemeinsame strategie
ist der höhepunkt der welle erreicht die
korona zahlen gäben hoffnung dass
beschränkungen schon bald gelockert
werden können
und historische medaille für das
deutsche team christoph wallroth er ist
erster deutscher olympiasieger im
skeleton alexander jung holte silber
[Musik]
die frage wie sich ein krieg in europa
verhindern lässt steht ja seit wochen im
fokus der weltpolitik und wie brenzlig
die situation ist zeigt eine von
us-präsident beiden eilig einberufene
große telefonkonferenz die seit ca 2
stunden läuft mit dabei der
bundeskanzler frankreichs präsident und
auch der chef der nato
amerikanische bürgerinnen und bürger
sollten die ukraine jetzt verlassen hat
der us-präsident beiden zuvor in einem
fernsehinterview gesagt russland lässt
sein militär sprechen kampfschiffe im
schwarzen meer manöver in belarus
soldaten im grenzgebiet alles nur zur
übung sagt moskau und sieht sich selbst
bedroht andreas kühner ist fasst
zusammen es
ist nicht ganz klar was russland meint
aber es ist ein gravierender vorwurf das
moskauer außenministerium stellt die
sicherheit seiner botschaft in kiew in
frage und erweckt alle diplomaten zu
evakuieren um sie vor provokationen der
ukrainischen regierung zu schützen die
stimmung wird schlechter in kiew
mittlerweile rufen die niederlande japan
kanada und die usa ihre bürger zur
ausreise auf
amerikaner sollen ideen jetzt wir haben
es mit einer der größten armeen der welt
zu tun die dinge könnten schnell außer
kontrolle geraten in berlin am tegeler
see beginnt gestern ein weiterer versuch
die lage in der ost ukraine zu
entschärfen die zwei einflussreichsten
diplomaten deutschlands und frankreichs
haben putins persönlichen berater
dimitri kosak und selen cigs rechte hand
andere ja mag in einen raum bekommen als
die vertreter der verfeindeten staaten
spät in der nacht auseinander gehen
haben sie keinen fortschritt zu
verkünden im gegenteil
leider leider sind die verhandlungen
ohne greifbare ergebnisse zu ende
gegangen
heute konnten wir uns auf kein
gemeinsames dokument einigen obwohl wir
neun stunden miteinander diskutiert
haben
russland beschuldigt die ukraine den
vereinbarten friedensplan nicht
umzusetzen beide seiten sind aber bereit
sich schnell wieder zu treffen
spektakulär die zahl der teilnehmer die
us präsident biden am abend zusammen
schalten lässt die staatschefs von
frankreich polen rumänien die
regierungschefs von deutschland kanada
italien großbritannien sowie die chefs
der nato und der eu derwesten sucht rat
holen wird theo koll dazu in berlin theo
warum auf einmal diese blitz konferenz
einberufen von us-präsident was steckt
dahinter also ganz offensichtlich so ist
hier in berlin zu hören steckt dahinter
die absicht des us-präsidenten seinen
wichtigsten verbündeten klar zu machen
für wie ernst er die aktuelle lage hält
oder joe biden wollte offensichtlich vor
allem den immer weitergehenden aufbauen
russische militär rund um die ukraine
besprechen nicht zuletzt nachdem
russland ja landungsschiffe aus der
ostsee ins schwarze meer verlegt hat der
norwegische
militärgeheimdienst wird hier zitiert
dass russland mittlerweile alle nötigen
mittel habe von einer kleinen invasion
im osten der ukraine bis hin zu einer
kompletten besetzung des landes der us
außenminister waren sogar vor einen
russischen angriff noch während der
olympischen spiele des telefonats wurde
mir vor wenigen minuten berichtet ist
offensichtlich zu ende gegangen und drei
punkte wurden mir genannt erstens die
lage ist zitat sehr ernst zweitens
entschlossenheit zu schnellen und
tiefgreifenden sanktionen und drittens
weitere diplomatische versuche zur
deinstallation danke für diese
einordnung und neuigkeiten theo koll
nach berlin jetzt ein besonderer blick
auf corona in deutschland deswegen
besonders weil wir uns in einer
bedeutsamen phase befinden nicht nur der
gesundheitsminister hatte ja für mitte
februar den scheitelpunkt der fünfte
welle prognostiziert die anzeichen dafür
die mehren sich jedenfalls die sieben
tage incidents ist heute nur noch leicht
gestiegen auf
1400 72,2 und die zahl der gemeldeten
neuinfektionen die ging erstmals wieder
etwas zurück
240.000
172 heute rund
8700 weniger als vor einer woche und
knapp 7700 weniger als gestern es sieht
also ganz danach aus als würde der
scheitelpunkt der omicron welle bald
erreicht sein julia schröter
in deutschland steckt mitten in der
fünften welle aber die dynamik nimmt ab
zuletzt war der anstieg im vergleich zur
vorwoche 14 prozent davor war er noch
deutlich höher 34 prozent der
scheitelpunkt der welle rückt offenbar
näher
wenn wir jetzt so weitermachen wie wir
im moment da stehen dann werden wir
ziemlich sicher in den nächsten 14 tagen
diesen scheitelpunkt erreichen
vielleicht sogar relativ schnell das
heißt jetzt ist der zeitpunkt auch über
lockerungsmaßnahmen nachzudenken um sie
dann systematisch durchzuführen wenn der
scheitelpunkt überschritten ist wenn die
zahlen nach unten gehen in einigen
bundesländern sinken die fallzahlen
bereits in schleswig holstein hamburg
bremen und berlin
in den übrigen ländern steigen die
zahlen weiter an in sachsen
sachsen-anhalt und thüringen kommt die
mikrowelle erst jetzt richtig an hier
steigen die zahlen noch massiv wie sich
all das auf die krankenhäuser auswirkt
zeigen jetzt neue daten der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft sie werden
werktäglich aktualisierte das ziel das
geschehen besser abbilden speziell auch
auf den normalen stationen dort liegen
derzeit 15
1926 corona patienten 20
als in der vorwoche auf
intensivstationen werden
2395 infizierte behandelt der anstieg
hier 5,9 prozent die belegungszahlen
genau zu kennen sei relevant heißt es
sie zeigt auch wie schwer ist eigentlich
der verlauf wie schwer ist diese welle
bezogen auf das thema hospitalisierung
und sie dient damit der politischen
steuerung und der einschätzung der lage
von der krankenhausgesellschaft kommt
mittlerweile entwarnung eine überlastung
der kliniken drohe nicht mehr
wir haben es gehört die experten leiten
von diesen entwicklungen ab dass man
langsam aber sicher lockerungsmaßnahmen
auf den weg bringen kann die politik hat
es vernommen und reagiert entsprechend
sowie der bundeskanzler der heute im
bundesrat war mehr von heike slansky
traditionelle antrittbesuch im bundesrat
der kanzler stellt sein
regierungsprogramm vor dabei lässt
scholz durchblicken dass er wie viele
bundesländer bereits beschlossen haben
erste lockerungen befürwortet die
wissenschaftlichen prognosen zeigen uns
dass der höhepunkt der welle in sicht
ist das erlaubt uns beim bund länder
treffen nächste woche einen ersten
öffnung schritt und dann weitere für das
frühjahr in den blick zu nehmen die
ampel koalition uneins der eigene
gesundheitsminister warnt auf die grünen
plädieren für vorsicht die liberalen
hingegen machen druck fordern das ende
aller einschränkungen
die maßnahmen die wir in deutschland
jetzt noch haben anders als andere
europäische länder die bereits gelockert
haben da müssen wir jetzt auch in
richtung lockerung gehen deswegen ist ja
mein vorschlag jetzt mit dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
lockerung anzufangen die öffnung
anzufangen beispielsweise zweig im
einzelhandel abzuschaffen und dann
spätestens bis zum 19 märz vollständig
wieder zu öffnen jeden tag sterben mit
schwankungen zwischen
150 und 200 menschen pro tag ich finde
es schade dass wir uns dann fast schon
gewöhnt haben und daher sehe ich einfach
nicht den spielraum für schneller
lockerung zweig zweig plus masken welche
wann und wo auch die union ist für eine
behutsame aufhebung von
grundrechtseingriffen allerdings müsse
man aufpassen dass man dieses tempo
nicht zu forsch angeht damit wir nicht
ganz schnell wieder in eine situation
kommen die uns vor große
herausforderungen stellt kommenden
mittwoch bund länder runde im kanzleramt
tag der weichenstellung was wann
gelockert wird
unter anderem zum thema lockerungen gibt
es heute auch ganz neue zahlen vom zdf
politbarometer die besprechen wir uns
mit matthias fornoff alle matthias
sogenannte wie schätzen die deutschen in
die krone der lage gerade einmal die
befragten sind schon etwas gelassener
weil sie die eigene gesundheit weniger
gefährdet sehen als noch vor wochen
entsprechend wächst der wunsch nach
lockerungen die korona maßnahmen sollten
schon jetzt gelockert werden sagen 23
prozent in zwei bis drei wochen finden
38 prozent ebenfalls 38 prozent sind im
team vorsicht und würden noch länger mit
lockerungen warten
weiterhin ist eine mehrheit für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht sollte man die
beschlossene impfpflicht für personal im
gesundheitsbereich aussetzen rund ein
drittel wäre dafür eine deutliche
mehrheit von 63 prozent ist aber gegen
das aussetzen und so hat es heute ja
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
entschieden matthias wir sprechen gleich
weiter in einem eilverfahren hat k s
oder nämlich vorläufig grünes licht für
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
gegeben und über die hintergründe jetzt
birgit franke
lina body tanner aus litauen seit sieben
jahren arbeitet sie in deutschland als
pflegehilfskraft zu besucht alte
menschen unterstützt sie beim anziehen
und im haushalt doch wie lange noch das
weiß sie nicht denn dies ungeimpft fühlt
sich auch ohne impfung sicher die
impfpflicht überfordert sie
nun gehe ich weiß nicht was soll ich
machen
ihr lag eine andere arbeit ihr
pflegedienst leiter findet die
impfpflicht ungerecht
langjährige mitarbeiter die durch die
ganze corona zeit treu in jeder krise
dagestanden haben werden mehr oder
weniger dadurch abgestraft doch das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
impfpflicht für pflegekräfte ärzte und
krankenhauspersonal heute vorläufig
bestätigt impfungen seien wichtig um
alte und vor erkrankte zu schützen ihr
schutz wiege schwerer als die nachteile
für die im pflichtigen berufsgruppen das
zentrale argument der verfassungsrichter
die wahrscheinlichkeit durch eine
impfung folgeschäden davon zu tragen sei
sehr gering wohingegen die
wahrscheinlichkeit an corona zu
erkranken dass sogar schwer und sogar zu
sterben sehr viel höher sei der deutsche
pflegerat steht zwar hinter dem impfen
fürchtet aber versorgungsengpässe der
gesetzgeber muss nach steuern und muss
klar sagen was passiert in der situation
wo wir
mitarbeitende freistellen und dadurch
versorgung nicht mehr sichern können
doch karlsruhe hat vorerst grünes licht
gegeben die nabu die tenne muss sich nun
wohl bis mitte märz entscheiden für die
impfung oder einen neuen job
und wir sprechen weiter über das
aktuelle zdf-politbarometer mit matthias
fornoff matthias es gab viel kritik am
kanzler zuletzt wie kommt seine arbeit
aktuell an es gibt mehrheitlich weiter
zustimmung zum neuen bundeskanzler die
ist aber rückläufig und auch stolz macht
seine arbeit gut finden 56 prozent
schlecht sagen 34 prozent und zwei
drittel finden dass er eher keine
führungsstärke zeigt dieser eindruck
schadet der spd bis jetzt nicht wenn am
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme sie auf
25 prozent plus 1 cdu/csu gleich auf 25
prozent plus 2 grüne 16 - zwei fdp 9 -1
afd 11 plus 1 und linke 6 prozent minus
1 die union macht also verlorenen boden
gut die ampel regierung hätte aber
weiter eine mehrheit interessante zahlen
fielen dank matthias fornoff
und das ausführliche politbarometer gibt
es wie immer im heute-journal ab 22 uhr
auch in unserer zdf heute app finden sie
alle zahlen und umfragewerte zum
beispiel die zu den beliebtesten
politikern in deutschland
ein viertel des handels zwischen den usa
und kanada rollt normalerweise über eine
brücke die msi bridge zwischen detroit
und windsor aber seit tagen geht hier
nichts mehr trucker blockieren die
zufahrtsstraßen zu mehreren
grenzübergängen aus protest gegen korona
maßnahmen mit gravierenden auswirkungen
auf die wirtschaft autofabriken in
beiden ländern mussten ihre produktion
zurückfahren oder zeitweise stoppen
jetzt der blick in die türkei wo die
menschen unter einer immensen inflation
leiden im januar mussten sie knapp 50
prozent tiefer in die tasche greifen als
anfang 2000 21 und schon damals lag die
teuerung bei rund 15 zurzeit besonders
heftig die energiekosten weil die lehrer
international wenig kaufkraft hat immer
mehr bürger protestieren verbrennen
sogar ihre stromrechnungen tenor die
regierung soll endlich eingreifen jörg
brase von 7.000 lehrer im dezember auf
20.000 im januar rund 1300 euro die
stromrechnung hat sich verdreifacht
theaterbesitzer kalaydo an weiß nicht
mehr weiter lebensmittel sind teurer
geworden jetzt noch die energiepreise er
hat beschlossen die rechnung nicht mehr
zu bezahlen
die preiserhöhung muss rückgängig
gemacht werden es ist unmöglich das zu
bezahlen wir haben kein geld wie sollen
wir das schaffen
im ganzen land brennen aus protest strom
und gasrechnungen ende dezember hatte
der präsident die weltweit gestiegenen
energiepreise teilweise an die
verbraucher weiter gegeben die sind
sauer doch präsident erdogan meinte
heute eine notlage könne er nicht
erkennen
die lage ist nicht so ernst wie es die
opposition ständig herausschreit
wir haben wirklich alle anstrengungen
unternommen um die lage für unsere
bürger zu verbessern
die aber spüren davon kaum etwas im
gegenteil knapp 50 prozent inflation im
januar so die offizielle zahl und selbst
dieser extrem hohe wert wird von
experten angezweifelt
ich denke dass es in der türkei derzeit
eine inflation zwischen 130 und 150
prozent gibt und sie steigt von tag zu
tag weiter die jüngsten
strompreiserhöhungen haben die menschen
ins mark getroffen ebenso wie die hohen
benzinpreise
wie hier die kurierfahrer in istanbul so
kämpfen auch andere branchen in der
türkei um höhere löhne denn weitere
preissteigerungen sind absehbar
glashütte dieser name steht schon seit
fast zwei jahrhunderten für sehr teure
luxus uhren eine mechanische
meisterleistung aus glashütte im
erzgebirge die gerne kopiert wird damit
soll jetzt schluss sein der bundesrat
hat nämlich beschlossen ab heute ist der
name geschützt und das ist auch gut für
die rund 1700 mitarbeitende das heißt
steht glashütte auf dem ziffernblatt
wurde die teile der uhr zu mehr als 50
prozent eben glashütte produziert
und wir sind bei sehr guten sport
nachrichten und katja es geht wieder um
gold für deutsche kann man so sagen auf
dem bauch voran mit dem kopf auch noch
und das mit mehr als 120 km/h sind
christopher grund aktie heute zu olympia
gold und silber im skeleton gerast und
diese zwei medaillen die gehen in die
geschichtsbücher ein
christopher roth er ist erster deutsche
goldmedaillengewinner im skeleton größte
erfolg in der karriere des 29 jährigen
nach vier läufen rus der weltmeister mit
knapp sieben zehntel vorsprung vor
seinem teamkollegen axel jung ins ziel
ich habe mir das so hart erarbeitet und
ich weiß nicht ist es alles noch so
unreal aber ich bin unfassbar stolz auf
mich auf platz 2 axel jung für den
30-jährigen ein happy end erst kurz vor
den spielen hatte er sich mit corona
infiziert noch bei der ankunft in peking
positiv getestet jetzt gewinnt
überraschend silber
ich will nach hause kommen und allen die
medaille zeigen ich will dass sie jeder
sehen kann und ja halt stolz auf mich
ist gold und silber im skeleton der
männer für deutschland bronze holt wenn
dann ja für china
der historische ist nur leider im
negativen heute im biathlon in dem die
dsv frauen das schlechteste sprint
ergebnis der deutschen olympia-
geschichte abgeliefert haben denise
herrmann vor vier tagen noch
olympiasiegerin wurde nur 22 vanessa
vogt als beste deutsche 18 es gewann die
norwegerinnen reiseland der könig der
halfpipe shawn white tritt ab mit platz
vier in der heutigen snowboard
entscheidung white prägte fast zwei
jahrzehnte diesen sport in der halfpipe
wurde dreimal olympiasieger und zeigte
auch im schnee von zhangjiakou dass man
mit 35 noch fliegen kann dieser patzer
im letzten run aber kostete ihm die
medaille tränen zum abschied obwohl er
zitat eigentlich nicht weinen wollte
gold holte der japaner yuki hirano
das russische olympia komitee kämpft
weiter um das startrecht der unter
dopingverdacht stehenden
eiskunstläuferin camila wally war am
dienstag soll die 15-jährige eigentlich
gold im einzel holen jetzt muss der cas
entscheiden nun ist er gefordert der
internationale sportgerichtshof cas in
der causa der 15 jährigen russischen
athleten camelia wahl war nach ihrer
doping probe vom 25 dezember bei den
russischen meisterschaften wurde ihr
positives ergebnis erst einen tag nach
ihrer kür bei den olympischen spielen am
montag bekannt gefunden wurde teamed up
sie den ein herzmittel das den blutfluss
verbessert und die ausdauer steigern
kann das ioc will eine klärung durch die
sportrichter
es ist sehr wichtig für alle beteiligten
nicht zuletzt für die betroffene 15
jährige athlet hin dass es ein
ordnungsgemäßes verfahren gibt dass alle
vertrauen in die getroffenen
entscheidungen haben können
am dienstag steht das kurzprogramm im
eiskunstlauf an mit einer möglichen
starterin camila vallejo war doch davor
soll der kasse entscheiden
was man in 48 stunden eine entscheidung
näher vielen dank hat ja sie dürfen sich
freuen es gibt nämlich viel sonne am
wochenende mehr gleich von katja
horneffer um 22 uhr meldet sich
christian sievers mit dem heute-journal
und vom gesamten 19 uhr heute team schön
start ins wochenende machen sich einen
schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend wurden sie heute auch
durchgerüttelt durch kräftige
schneefälle hier rosa markiert oder
durch den heftigen regen blau markiert
oder was mir der wolken wirbel der hier
von der nordsee startete und bis nach
sachsen zog da gab es kräftige schauer
zum teil auch kurze gewitter jetzt aber
wird es doch von westen deutlich
freundlicher und das liegt an dem hoch
ingo das sieht morgen schon weiter
richtung schwarzes meer wolken sind
dabei uns mangelware und deswegen wird
es heute nacht auch sehr kalt an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee sinken die
werte bis minus 1 grad am alpenrand geht
es bis minus 11 grad runter in der nacht
kann es noch ein paar schneeschauer
geben so zwischen dem thüringer wald und
im bayerischen wald machen sie sich also
noch mal auf straßenglätte gefasst
morgen dann aber strahlt die sonne es
gibt nur wenige harmlose wolken und die
temperaturen liegen zwischen 2 grad in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen und maximal
9 grad am rhein am mildesten wird es
wahrscheinlich so rund um karlsruhe am
sonntag nimmt dann der südwind deutlich
zu und damit kann es am oberrhein bis zu
14 grad mild werden sonst ändert sich
wenig die neue woche startet sehr viel
weniger schönes wochenende